those unaware Michael Reeves is the
person that I fought last year at
Creator clash and he completely beat me
up so today we're sitting down with him
and confronting him on exactly what
happened exactly what he's been up to
since then what's an average day look
like for you wake up crack life instead
nice Fortnight
and some of the crazy projects he's
working on currently behind the scenes
that you haven't even heard about yet so
with that said make sure to subscribe
hit the like button and before we get
into it we gotta thank today's sponsor
Creative Juice look if you're a Creator
you've probably realized unfortunately
that creating content is only a very
small part of your business like there's
so many other things that just take up
your time that aren't really that fun
and managing finances taxes and expenses
can be incredibly overwhelming
especially if you're not sure which
transactions are business or personal
use right Ranch and that's why Creative
Juice is a perfect solution for creators
just like you not only do they offer a
business banking account with a debit
card and rewards but they also offer
automated and personalized tax tools
specifically for creators if you don't
know where to begin with taxes begin
with juice now you could categorize your
expenses in real time to simplify
write-offs for all expense types like
your daily Starbucks juice also offers a
1099 IRS compliant tool that allows you
to pay your contractors efficiently I do
my favorite part is that you get access
to Creator minded CPAs that'll help do
your taxes for you let juice automate
your business simplify your taxes and
provide the funding you need to focus on
what you enjoy the most which is
creating so sign up for a free Creative
Juice business banking account with the
link down below or visit getjuice.com
and the link is down below in the
description Jack now let's get back to
the video what do you what have you been
up to today today yeah what was your day
like today
um I was hanging out with Lily uh my
girlfriend uh we like this one around we
took I took her to like a voiceover
thing she does like voice over work so I
like took her to that we went grabbed
some food
um I went home just like worked a little
bit what type of voiceover work is it is
it for like animations or something like
anime like shows different trailers like
pretty much whatever did she study that
in college is she just natural no I
think well she's like pretty good at
Naturally but then she's also like
taking like a bunch of classes and she's
been like doing it for a while so really
yeah yeah what is she booked has she
booked anything yet yeah she's done a
lot she was actually in a gentian impact
you know again that is that uh it's like
an anime it's like the world's largest
anime game you know like you know weebs
we weebs you know weeds yeah weeds weeb
is like someone who like watches anime
yeah is a weeb why is it why is a weeb
it's a I think that's the weeaboo is the
Japanese word for like loser and so
refurned it to weeb oh I didn't know
that I didn't know it okay so right here
I'm actually pulling this out of my all
the way and I have no idea what I'm
talking about wheel boo is not a
Japanese word it is a made-up word on
4chan that someone use and then I here I
will pretend to talk about it like I
know that it is a like I know that it's
a Japanese word like I know that I know
what it means but I don't it's all
coming out of my ass so it's not a good
term like no you don't want to be called
a weave people proudly wear the badges
yeah yeah yeah no but it's become more
way more socially acceptable like in
recent times yeah like like when like
middle school for me you were like you
hid that yeah
um and now you're like cool if you wear
like a Naruto shirt are you a weeb no I
mean I don't watch like that much anime
yeah I have like a you know I watch a
lot but yeah not like an animal
anime animal yeah yeah exactly would you
do voice over yourself yeah um yeah I
would give it a shot I would give it a
shot really rattle off a few lines dude
yeah dude like I feel like there's got
to be a company out there who wants your
voice I think they're actually I am
talking to one right now actually they
just I think they're making a video game
and they just like need a random and I
said I'd do it that's fine and what
would that entail like what would you
say
use that for like a sound effect right
what sound effect would that be like you
get hit or something like you're
underwater in the underwater scene I'm
struggling again
can you license that and sell it yeah
you gotta suck in air at the same time
yeah oh yeah and do it yeah no it's good
that's a good yeah that was good that
was good it was fantastic that was wet
that was that was a voice that was good
I wanted to be a voiceover actor really
and really when I was a kid voice I feel
like for what yeah uh so when I was a
kid there was this uh this group called
The cranky anchors okay and they do
these prank phone calls and I got a CD
of it and I wanted to be like the Crank
Yankers and they'd make these phone
calls to people and they do different
accents and like different voices and
they prank them on the phone so I got
really into that so I started cranky
anchors was it a YouTube channel
Jack this is like 2003. no no
television this was a CD oh okay it was
a CD that you bought it crank anchors so
I developed this voice of a grandma okay
I would call up uh usually grocery
stores I'd be like hi I want to know if
you have something for sale and you know
it's not a plan that sounds like my
grandma really yeah kind of yeah
yeah it's uh it's been quite a while but
I'd call up these stores and just like
just have fun with with my friends
oh it was always someone else's phone we
put it on speakerphone because I didn't
have a cell phone back then so I'd use
someone else yeah type Star 86 right oh
yeah yeah star six seven I think okay
seven I call up we get a laugh out of it
and we do the next one yeah so I really
wanted to get into voiceovers for a
while oh that's cool yeah dude there's
still time yeah still gonna do it yeah
so we got to talk about some things
because last time we had you on we had
this big disagreement well I wouldn't
say we I would say mostly between you
and Graham let's save that for later you
want to save that first like Michael
posted his first video in like two years
okay let's talk about it let's talk
about the video you said you were very
late on it right I was just about the
bottom of that boxing video Yeah I
wanted that to come out like the same
month
and then seven months passed yeah what
happened yeah like
someone like I made a thing where like
you bought it forces you to box with
like electricity in your arms and like I
finished the [__] like the part where
it forces you to like punch like
10 months ago and then I was like that's
pretty cool and funny and then I was
like okay what if I and that was it that
was the whole plan like it was just the
arms and then I was like okay what if
you did like a rail system and like
moved the people I was like that would
be funny and I predicted that that would
take two weeks and it took maybe three
or four months to like actually get that
done
um why what was what was so complicated
about the rail system because yeah like
ordered the rails right I ordered the
rails from like China
um it needed to be pretty hefty rails
because it needed like to experience a
lot of like Dynamic force and like a lot
of
ways because there's like because
there's like lifting Force because like
it's like your body and then you like
you know if something's like straight up
and it does this it like Falls over a
little bit right you know yeah so you're
like experiencing like a lifting thing
so it has to like take off lifting Force
so okay I don't know I ordered these
rails from China on AliExpress and they
were good they worked um custom-made or
did you have to no no they're just like
huge guide rails built for like CNC
Machining stuff so like you know if like
a machine that you know just like
creates has like a huge spindle and like
Cuts metal and you need like a really
bulky rail can they just sell it in like
different sizes
so I bought like in the knockoff version
of that I think like if you bought like
the good quality high wind version of
that it would have been like five or six
thousand dollars but these were like
like 800 or less kind of yeah 800 seems
like a lot though for the rails I mean
it's a lot of Steel and it's like
compared to like the the good one the
the one that's like an industry standard
high quality one it's like it's almost
nothing like who would buy who would buy
your rails that you buy around yeah well
my wife actually were destroyed by the
Reigns recently in Los Angeles they were
fully flooded my garage your garage was
fully [__] oh yeah dude like two
inches really um yeah the place I live
at has a garage that is like below
ground level but just by like three
inches but that's enough to just get
absolutely [__] on by any random happens
in L.A did you just wake up one morning
go to the garage and just dude covered
yeah and it's like it's so [__] bad
and they're just rust everywhere like
destroyed the thing yeah do you have
renters insurance
um no maybe no I think I do actually to
rent the house I think I do after I
think you have to yeah they would pay
for it yeah you can tally up how much
money you lost on that and they'll
reimburse you for rails yeah maybe at
the end of the least I really like this
house
like you pay 20 a month and you call
them up for yourself I do I do have that
yeah yeah so you call them up and say
hey I got a a boxing thing in the garage
they're gonna be on Rails it's destroyed
here is my cost on it yeah here's my
receipt that I should they'll reimburse
you for that sort of stuff if your
property's damaged yeah yeah I should
yeah so sometimes like when it's raining
I have to go out there with the shop vac
and like pump the water out from the
floor so my doesn't get destroyed so you
made this robot how'd that take you
three months dude just the rail part was
just so [__] like I I I ordered the
wrong rails from China and then I had
like order them again really yeah dude I
was so stupid I think I was just like
out of it that day and I like measured
the size that they had to travel but
like I did not realize that like I
didn't think about the fact it had to
move so it actually had to be double
that size uh which sucked um so it's
just like a lot of waiting for China to
do it I to drill 40 holes in the
concrete of my garage
um to get to support it it's bolted to
the concrete yeah because it's like a
lot of force going through that like
you're moving so it's just
steel drilled in a concrete
holding these big plates and rails down
right so is your landlord not like
that's what I'm thinking about that so I
so the garage is [__] it's like
absolutely [__] like this
everything's off kilter I called an
electrician to do my lights and he said
I literally cannot touch this wiring
system it's so bad that I might lose my
license so it's like a [__] garage so
it's like I'll fill in the holes you
know I'll do it when I leave okay like
it's not like
there's like a two inch lip to get in
the garage like it's a Concrete [__] lip
that they put in like hopefully to keep
the rain out it does not keep the rain
out if anything it holds the rain in
like a hole like a toilet bowl oh my God
so I'm not destroying anything crazy
nice okay yeah but I'll fill it in
before I leave as like like you know
like to be nice sure
um but like the drywalls like you can
kick the drywall lightly and it falls
apart how old is the house I'm not sure
okay yeah old enough to have like a few
additions put on it so okay yeah yeah
quite quite old I mean I really like it
though okay yeah so once you start this
video that got posted seven months after
that
yeah I think it was uh well you must
have started it what after Ian reached
out to you okay but still that was like
a year and a half yeah basically yeah
yeah something like so you started about
a year and a half ago yeah and then it
started like getting serious and then
credit clash and then yeah but you have
an interesting process with your videos
of like you explained it the first time
of like you'll come up with the idea
film just like the intro edit that and
then as you go you'll just throw it on
and like keep editing yeah like
throughout then you've done at the very
end yeah yeah
um that is how I like to do it yeah
sometimes like when I have to not do
that I hate it listen guys I grow an
uncanny amount of hair and it's
everywhere
but thankfully for me and uh your Tinder
dates Jack don't forget them I use
today's sponsor manscaped manscaped is
the ultimate grooming tool for men
they're not only the leaders in the
below the waist grooming but they're
also now going even further with their
brand new whacker 2.0 the weed whacker
2.0 offers improved blades and skin safe
technology so you can clean up your
manholes painlessly holes yes Graham
holes and I also use them for beard
trimming as well yeah no not not the
same one Graham for that I use the beard
hedger Pro kit which upon purchase
includes a cordless electric beard
hedger four dermatologist tested
formulations and three free gifts well I
like free things seriously guys I've
been using manscape for years now and
they have products I recommend to my
friends off camera and don't forget you
can also get 20 off your order plus free
shipping when you use the code ich at
manscape.com or you could use the link
Down Below in the description to try it
out today once again guys that's
manscape.com and use code ich to get 20
off in free shipping always use the
right tools for the job with manscaped
thank you so much manscaped let's get
back to the podcast enjoy I got into
motorcycles recently you did um and so
it was it's kind of about that
motorcycle is dangerous don't ride it
unless you take the course and do all
the things you know it it's probably the
most dangerous thing like you can do
that's legal normally on the street so I
have almost been hit so many times so
don't just go Ryan around like a freak
yeah take the course and get your
license and try not to have them steal
your organs all right bye I went on a
adventure in the deserts of San Diego
um by myself which is fun uh the
motorcycle yeah yeah was the adventure
um just like a day or two but it was it
was fun enough like there's you know a
lot of things went wrong so that's good
that's good what goes wrong with the
motorcycle the motorcycle looks totally
fine actually yeah my truck dude I got
this truck from the city of like like of
La it's like white you know those trucks
like the city truck I know like it's
just a white truck and it's got like no
just like a pickup truck and it's got
like the orange light on top did you buy
it yeah it was like four thousand
dollars okay well because it's a second
hand City truck sure and it's like 20
years old it's only got 80 000 miles on
it somehow but like I can do anything I
can park anywhere and I flip the light
on dude
I had to call them and be like hey don't
take the light off I want that light
yeah after they like get use out of them
they'll give them to like people to sell
like whoever used cars guys and I bought
it from them and dude I can go and I can
do anything I'm like God in the truck
it's incredible I like like if I one
time I was like pick my girlfriend up
yeah there's a ton of Uber drivers I
just turn the light on and honked
everyone was out are you serious dude I
got a [__] um High Vis vest in the
glove compartment
just throwing the hive is vest dude
instead of getting junk removal I make
so much trash at my house I throw in the
back of the truck they drive around the
place I live I just put on The Hive this
vest and dump it in anyone's dumpster
and like apartment complex dumpsters
restaurant dumpsters yeah like on trash
day you know they're throwing it away
anyway and no one stops you because
you're in a white truck you're in a
white truck with a light on top and
you're wearing a hyvest
[Laughter]
late at night preferably so nobody sees
and I try to be really quiet too and I
put in the trash so gently so that it
doesn't make any sound it's getting
thrown away anyway it is like it's it's
fine yeah I have that problem as well
you know they sell police cars just like
that really with the lights on and
everything and are those retro fitted to
be like faster and like better I don't
know if they are but there was a Crown
Victoria that was for sale in Vegas it
was forty five hundred dollars
legitimately with like the lights the
proper lights the cage in the back the
the yeah two lights in front that's
funny the people who buy those are weird
though unless it's like for fun so I was
tempted to get one I think parking
outside of the house I just keep it
there because there's security it's not
like your daily driver you know but it's
weird yeah thing but I think it would be
cool that would be cool it'd be really
neat why didn't I do it thanks I just
thought it's a waste of money like
realistically I thought it I thought
it'd be fun to park it out front of the
house everyone comes up they're like oh
he's got a cop car in the front yeah uh
and then I drive it every now and then I
thought it would just be cool that
doesn't sound kind of but then I thought
like realistically it's like five grand
let's say all in I don't need that you
don't need the phone I don't need that I
don't need that in my life right now
yeah
so where do you get the inspiration to
buy the city car like I've never thought
about buying something yeah it's great
um I was just looking for a truck to put
my motorcycle in and I just have on
Craigslist yeah on Craigslist yeah yeah
yeah actually right after the fight I
took like a dirt biking lesson I thought
it was really fun huh so oh you're like
dirt biking not motorcycle oh I do both
but um I got one that can like go on the
dirt on the road oh nice it's like it's
not like a Harley or anything like that
no no like what is it like a dual sport
it's like a uh KTM it's a Yamaha Yamaha
250 yeah it's like a nice little like
you know go in the desert but then also
right on the road it's fun yeah that is
how much 150 I don't know like
it was new yeah it was new but it also
gets like whenever I fill it with gas
it's like eight dollars
why I was
I think I was driving back from Vegas
one day yeah
um well there were like a couple things
one was like this uh YouTuber uh you
know Casey neistat yeah his brother he
has a brother fan neistat yeah and he
had a really cool motorcycle
um Series where he like I think it was
footage from like 10 years ago but he
like went across the us and that looked
really fun and also I was driving back
from Vegas once and I saw a dude on a
dirt bike and I thought that looks super
sick and so
I I got I took a dirt bike lesson now
when you were driving back from Vegas
you had a guy on the dirt bike was that
like not on the road but like off of the
road yeah there's Trails
yeah yeah yeah how was it how was my
experience yeah it was what it lived up
to be yeah I don't like doing hitting
jumps I just like going to cool spots
that cars can't go to which is sweet
there's a couple cool spots like
um above La there's this place called
like roller Flats like you go like 50
miles up a hill like you climb a
mountain and then on the other side it's
like a big old Lake which is really
sweet
um yeah yeah I was thinking about like
doing some like camping or something
like 310 and then so now every you know
how you're talking like it took what 10
minutes to get like a mile a mile now
it's like actually like you know a
Mile's worth of time to get a mile oh
it's because you're just going in
between have you done that yeah yeah you
do that all the time yeah
is great it is it is for Los Angeles I
cannot drive a [__] car anymore it it
I think I was gonna take my bike over
here actually but yeah did this weird
yeah it was kind of was raining yeah
um but like just for transportation it's
super nice what was your first time like
doing that
um because you must have had a moment
they were like I could do it oh maybe
not yeah all right let me do it like
groceries at the start because the
stores what time what time of day that
match like at night first okay and then
like I was like oh during day this time
and then it was like oh dude I could do
that and then I got my license and um
you got your license after you did that
three years yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right yes yeah um I've never been pulled
over on it but
it's nice it's super dangerous I've
almost been hit so many fun times really
yeah it's [__] crazy I mean but it's
nice because like
like there's a traffic it's like it's
like I actually get to a place when
Google says I'll get to a place or
before I Google says I get to a place
yeah but is that worth the danger it's
uh the fun I think is is the channel in
between those two balances so
phonogrammed it is
fun what do you hate most about La I
don't know yeah yeah
I don't like like a I don't know like
um in Hawaii there's like not a lot of
barrier to entry to just like do
whatever you know it's like get food at
the minutes or the 7-Eleven it's a
7-Eleven food Superman just like go
there and then go to the beach and you
know it's like a 20 minute thing and or
like you know super easy just hop in a
car and do whatever's but here it's like
I almost you know you're stuck in
traffic and it's like ass and then
there's a lady yelling at you and then
someone almost hits you so yeah
it's just like a nice sure I was with
you on that I lived in LA or Santa
Monica I guess with graham in his guest
house for a year and I had a strong
distaste from my life I did not I liked
living that whole living situation was
amazing extremely grateful for that that
was fun but anytime I tried to leave
anywhere it was just like the biggest
pain in the butt and also Santa Monica
started going downhill a little bit like
it started getting dirtier it was a
little sketchier going out at night and
stuff like that so I was I just did not
like LA and I've maintained that for a
long time I feel you on that I like the
people and you know that's nice yeah I'm
kind of like enjoying it a little more
now because I'm like getting out of the
house now would you ever leave oh yeah
yeah yeah I want to live in Japan for a
year someday I could see that yeah yeah
just like cross that one off like The
Bucket List you could see PewDiePie up
there exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I can't believe this I've seen some
of his Vlogs there they're really
interesting it seems like it's fun to go
to like Tokyo and like spend like a
month or two there right yeah yeah have
you ever been never it is it's super fun
you should go really yeah and you can
also get some you can business expense
it and do your tax yeah well you really
can I mean like you expense the whole
trip and like I could Vlog it we do it
we do it yeah we do a vlog you know
research there yeah exactly do a podcast
yeah all your food's expensed dude it is
so fun what do you like about Japan I
enjoy the walkability of the cities like
pretty much anywhere you want to go you
can go like you can without a car which
is nice so you can like hop on
um
just generally you can walk and there's
like you know a great Corner Store the
7-Eleven food is also super good like
convenience store food which I like a
quick bite to eat um if you need to get
anywhere in a city you just like take a
train and the train system's like super
fast super easy not super nice once you
learn it I mean it's kind of
overwhelming at first but eventually
like
you like you know get a little card even
on your phone you can just tap your
phone on the little Turn Style and you
get in have it when you get out it
charge you automatically you don't worry
about it what if you don't speak
Japanese is it how easy is this now yeah
like it's pretty good it's pretty easy
right yeah I mean you can pick up like
the words that are like I'm sorry and
[__] you know
um how do you say I'm sorry uh sumimasen
sumimus
if you're like super
or like a casual or if you need to go
from City to City you can get on a
shinkansen like a bullet train yeah it
feels like it goes so fast it feels like
being on a plane just on the ground like
right before you take off but that's it
the whole way the whole way they go like
300 miles an hour it's [__] like when
it turns the tracks Bank a little bit
because it needs wow it's going so
[__] fast yeah it's so fast the air
pressure sometimes in the tunnels it
becomes super loud because it's pushing
such a high quantity of air yeah it
they're it's beautiful you can like just
get around the country on a train and
you can do anything there's like spot in
Tokyo where it's like it's called Golden
guy that I really liked it was like it's
a collection of like a hundred tiny bars
and each bar only says like five people
so like you you're like in an intimate
situation with your bartender and anyone
else in there like you have to talk to
them it's just like how it goes and so
you're like there's like super nice
people who like teach you a little
Japanese and you'll teach them a little
English or like uh if they don't speak
it good plug Google translate you like
meet both ways really yeah I had a
bartender she pulled out Google
translate and I pulled out Google
translate and it was like the [__]
yeah
and they give them back it was so fun it
was a blast that's cool yeah yeah what's
stopping you from going there now uh
like to live yeah
um I think a little probably a little
more time here like
um
I'm still here with my um
like our the lease on my current place
isn't up but I would do it I would
definitely do it sounds fun like for
like a year you know it'll be fun I
think that would be a blast right yeah I
could do I could do a week or two yeah
yeah you should you should go over just
for like I want vacation first I can't
get to travel anywhere like I I've done
I've done North America yeah done that
but yet to really see anything beyond
that yeah so that's something I'm
looking forward to you should do it yeah
it would be fun and you can make some
good content on it yeah there's so much
like randable to do in Japan yeah so we
got these um I'm gonna pop a pop it open
it's uh Happy death so we did a podcast
the other night with um John
and uh he's the CEO of happy Dad okay
and he gave us uh a whole bunch of these
that's nice so I'm gonna try it it's not
banana it's not it's not cold but
bananas it's very good yeah it's very
good nft on the side this is a goddamn
obnoxious
yeah I'm with you on that you don't want
any screenshots
I'm with you on that yeah no screenshots
of it though it does it's not bad
yeah I don't blame you what advice would
you give them for happy Dad like if if
you could I don't yeah I didn't think a
banana flavor with Seltzer would work
but it's quite good
they actually did a great job this was a
limited edition flavor they told us
something sold out and they're bringing
it back permanently I don't think it's
good yeah it tastes good tastes
delicious yeah
I feel like you should come out with
your own products or something like that
yeah happy dad's blown up I mean really
yeah for for a Seltzer they're really
doing well see this is where we can now
talk about the differing velocities
because Graham is now talking to Michael
about making his own product or service
he can then sell something right so the
last podcast like I kind of alluded to
earlier there was a big difference in
philosophy between both you and Graham
Graham was very much of the case like yo
why are you not grinding why are you not
pumping out a bunch of content why are
you not capitalizing striking while the
iron's hot like your stuff is blowing up
you could be making a ton of money yeah
you know and you were very much the type
we're like I'm having fun living the
life I'm I'm living right now like kind
of chilling a lot of the time but also
working of course when I need to and
also when I want to not really when I
feel like I have to you know yeah yeah I
should definitely work more I think we
can meet in the middle someday probably
probably you can go to Japan I can work
a little more I can do two videos here
no I'm not I'm not going dude if you had
someone just on you every day just like
you know waking you up at 7am be like
you gotta work
the best videos I would like this uh
yeah I'm excited to make this Vlog even
if I don't release it anywhere just like
maybe not you may not release it
anywhere let's throw it on my patreon
maybe those poor [__]
a year too oh dude they're the strongest
soldiers that have ever lived dude
that's poor man what do they get yeah
how much is the patreon and like what
what was included or whatever but uh
yeah
it's actually like they get so [__]
little and they're still there
crazy so I'm trying to throw them it's
not like a crazy amount of people but
Jesus Christ these but they're
dedicators yeah yeah so I'm gonna try
and give this video at least to patreon
uh before I if I ever post it but
definitely for patreon yeah how long do
you think this video is going to take in
the post-production oh I'm like six
minutes in I'm almost done okay I mean
yeah I got all the footage there's
nothing like really to improve on you
know it's just like a fun situation so
why are you content living the way that
you are right now you know working like
when you want to and taking like breaks
and and spending your free time like
having fun with your friends you are a
unicorn when it comes to that to have
the luxury to post like once a year yeah
and the one video you Postman blows up
everyone loves it to get my bank account
up I really could I really could but
um
I love it I don't know dude
yeah if I'm busy grinding everyone
else's lives go on as well so you know
can't get that back but like what's it
what's an average day look like for you
uh can wake up crack pipe instant nice
fortnite challenge
fortnite is actually a big part of my
days actually do you really play
fortnite a lot yeah yeah dude my
housemates [__] we [__] love
fortnite dude really yeah this is see
this is how uh yeah [__] Jack's
talking about pickleball I thought he
was [__] with me like unironically
this is this is my pickleball unironic
yeah I [__] love foreign
I actually kind of like it really yeah
yeah well they got me back in they added
like the cloud back the Dragon Ball Z
Cloud okay um I kind of like some of the
new guns too it took some getting used
to yeah it was the um the the event the
um the the there's always the start of
the Season event and this event was dog
[__] this was a really sad way to start
a season usually the really cool things
dude I had the saddest [__] story of
the saddest day of my life the saddest
day of my entire life
um worse than my dog dying worse than my
childhood dog perishing dude we [__]
my my roommates are out of town for like
a month plus seeing family they get back
the day that this new fortnite season
drops we Zoom to LAX we picked them up
all we're [__] talking about in the
car Fortnight this new season is gonna
be sick we get home
sit in our computers
straight dog [__] for an hour right like
it's the worst like starting event I've
ever seen in my life it was just like
terrible and then a black screen and it
says fortnite will return eventually and
the servers are down for the rest of the
day and like the next 72 hours and we
were [__] we were so sad this is the
lowest point in my entire I don't think
Graham feels any sympathy I don't get it
when you're saying you're saying season
like it's a show so yeah they come out
to they change the map up so yeah you're
going around killing people like stuff
yeah they keep it fresh you know if you
have the same [__] sure constantly so
season is like a big change lots of new
[__] okay yeah so we don't call it like
fortnite too no no because the same game
yeah okay yeah same game yeah dude I
[__] got on LinkedIn and I messaged
every Fortnight engineer no you didn't
someone responded no what did they say
she said it will be back in about
72 hours or like [__] 5 p.m the next
morning or something she responded it
was incredible and what did you say back
thank you well I mean thank you for
responding to me yeah I feel bad for
bugging them I did it kind of as a joke
but got it
yeah that's that's a fun thing I do with
my my housemates I'm not gonna lie
Graham there was probably a month of
time in my life probably honestly it's
probably three months where I was like
like at night oh yeah I was like
grinding fortnite and my housemates win
when was this this is probably recent no
it was just before the the launch of the
new season and I was like I was like
super into it and like come like seven
eight pm I would play for like three
hours every single night and I would
grind you know and I bought the pass and
everything
what's the point what's the point is
It's You Escape reality man so all the
worries that you have the anxieties of
the next day The Dread that you have of
the past that disappears and you if you
live in the present to get a winner
winner chicken dinner man they get the
victory Roy yeah absolute [__] rush
through your veins also um well they
make like winning a little more rare
than other games you know it's hard
really yeah because it's like only one
person or team can win out of like 100
people so it's like it's a validating
enjoyable time when you are the one yeah
um but also like it's fun for like if
you have a group of people you know it's
like connecting with your friends it's
like a fun group experience you know
it's like a teamwork thing you work
together towards a common goal and then
achieve it is fun what do you get for
winning You Get to cracking rights you
get sick you get to emote on the people
who lost
[__] on them what does that mean so you
you do a dance kill them and then you
like do a dance you at the end of the
game you gotta do that
you gotta do the L dance they can't see
you they can see you they can they can
yeah yeah I know it's literally just to
see the screen that says you won yeah
but it's just a good feeling it's like I
don't know why do people like games
where you build towards something like
Clash of Clans or like other games like
RPGs where you feel like you're
advancing and evolving yeah it's like a
sports I think where like it's similar
to sports you know you work together as
a team common goal and then like [__]
I don't know what is you know the high
school football team get they just get
to say hey we won you know their score
is bigger than the average score right
so yeah I just don't I don't I don't get
it that yeah
Michael probably doesn't understand your
constant focus on like you know doing
the business
documents and you'd be killing it in
fortnite dude
yeah it would be over you'd be a monster
I could see it I get addicted to things
though if I find something I really like
all I will do I know I just get all
hyped about that
really yeah because the thing is like
there's a learning curve just like if
you if you've never played a video game
before you got to learn how to use that
dude it is not a fun first video game
for sure yeah either a million more
video games that you'd like what would
you recommend for somebody getting into
video games
yeah play Minecraft or like if you like
a story if you're like I don't get a
video game
um story based game is good you know
because it's like it's like a movie okay
and you like GTA movies maybe
um so yeah you get to experience a movie
through your gameplay yeah I loved
Nintendo 64. that's kind of where I left
off yes was that what'd you play uh gosh
almost all of them my favorite games
Conker's Bad for a day probably one of
my favorite games uh I played
Banjo-Kazooie
Banjo-Tooie Super Mario yeah
um GoldenEye actually the two golden
eyes yeah and then the racing games were
really fun oh gosh and then um Yoshi
Yoshi's story oh yeah I think it was a
that was a fun one good games yeah yeah
I love those it's like the Mario one was
just a classic it was great Mario yeah I
got the magazines back then like I get
stuck and they sell these magazine so
like the tutorials yeah you're a gamer
dude yeah I loved it I would get stuck
at a level and then they'd sell those
like those cheat sheets yeah so I'd go
through and I find where the hidden
things are to go through and then I got
a game shot
oh my God that leveled me up yeah
because then I just get unlimited
everything that's where you ran off yeah
after that because it's not becoming fun
exactly
it just ruins the game it did oh I got
game short the big one was game shark
for Pokemon on the game boy yeah and I
would get all the rare candy so all of
my Pokemon would be level 100. I'd have
all the rare ones I had the Mew but then
I'd be trading the me with other kids in
class who didn't have the meal dude so
congratulations yeah it's so good that
you efficiented all the fun out of the
game
you can't struggle anymore after that
yeah because I get the master ball for
the Articuno I remember getting stuck on
that for like a week trying to catch
that Articuno yeah and then one game
shark done and yeah yeah you just
haven't I got it that's magical yeah oh
that's where it all changed uh are there
any cheating things with fortnite no
like people there's people Super Games
there was a dude that streamed himself
cheating on fortnite and he got banned
immediately you can download like
aimbots and stuff like that so you drop
in lobbies and then there's this like
software that basically finds the other
person's head and then moves the cursor
I think I saw it uh it was like a sunny
V2 video on that yeah about like the
video games people yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
we're showing that's like the thing just
like yeah yeah pretty much since the
start of every uh multiplayer game that
has been a problem yeah and so they're
getting more intense with the
anti-cheats and even in chess there's
like oh yeah alleged cheaters get into
your butt they're alleged yep do you
think that's what they say do you think
it's real I don't know I could have been
that's awesome
I think Mike that would be a great video
for you to do Mike Floyd made that I
think Mike Boyd made a yeah but you
could do it better dude it's like it
would probably be a taser dude
that's actually really smart people
could see you being really good at chess
that's the thing oh true so if you could
somehow trick like what's Hikaru or
something and you'd be like hey man I've
been training a ton yeah like the boat
has sisters and you beat them in Chicago
what was that Michael
nothing that would be good yeah that
would be funny yeah
I think you should do that I think
that's a that's a hit video there's 10
million view right there you get it
sponsored by someone will sponsor it
dude the big Adam evil sponsored company
yeah yeah yeah
that'd be sweet I'm gonna make it led
an LED RGB butt plugs in the dark yeah
do you feel much of a pressure to be
working harder right now
um like a little bit I kind of want to
make more videos so you want to make
more videos and what's the reason why
you want to make more videos because it
would be fun it would be sweet I guess
yeah yeah it would be nice it'd be nice
to have my first page on my YouTube
channel filled out
I think I'm on my second page now
actually when you go to like the video
wow you go to the second page I think I
want two pages that would be sick that
would be cool yeah yeah at least I'm
getting an easy one out of the Vlog that
was quick and easy that you have like
perfectionism like to a pretty serious
degree like you you it's hard for you to
feel content with the video Yeah I want
it to be good so yeah it takes yeah yeah
probably what would you say are the
limiting factors to you posting more
um
that effing dub in fortnite baby yeah
yeah
so fortnite didn't exist you would be
like posting a mindset about every
[__] week you would be posting every
day
but what about the guys that you you
play fortnite with like they have jobs
right yeah yeah they do do you play
solos no no no I always play it with
people okay yeah yeah so what do you do
when they're at work
I try to get some work done yeah yeah
yeah I don't know sometimes it's tough
to get through an edit but uh
do you just lose interest at a certain
point where it's like you spent so long
on something else like oh man I'm not
another day of this yeah sometimes yeah
yeah but
yeah so I'm gonna try and get it like
where
I have like a good grasp of the video
um or like the idea as a whole because
sometimes like I make like too many
auxiliary pieces of [__] you know like
like rails or like like for the boxing
video like um just like side things that
haven't like nothing to do with the
start of the video but I'll like you
know take like two or three weeks to
build them I'll be like that didn't
actually save any time for the for the
video making experience so yeah I'll
probably like cut down on on those and
just like maybe I'll see like how fast I
can make a video from like start to
finish
UNICEF needs to send them something so
they basically uh do the patreon and
they say like whatever you give us if
it's anything we're happy for it but we
just want to support you oh yeah for a
lot a lot of parts
oh are you going to Crater Clash too yes
dude I'm so excited you're going to yeah
screaming I'm gonna lose my [__]
voice again I lost my voice of the chess
boxing dude oh you went to that yeah how
was it that was sweet that was fun as
[__] actually really yeah yeah
um it's fun to be on the outside for
sure much more fun than doing it so
yeah yeah being on the outside is like
you're getting me excited really
anything and like just [__] behind
because like also we have like a unique
perspective where it's like you know how
it feels like you're doing that and
you're like [__] so glad it's not me
I don't know dude
yeah I can't wait dude I'm so excited
because I didn't invite you to do this
yeah yeah yeah we're gone yeah hell yeah
extremely excited yeah yeah I'm looking
forward to it did Ian invite you to go
to the second one yeah to like fight
yeah yeah I think everyone who fought in
the first got invited dude he [__] he
almost got me with I said the only guy
I'd fight again would be [__] um
[__] garyvee no way but there was no way
in the world that I gonna get scary V
because like garyvee's like he's like
our size you know so he is but isn't it
right that would be such a fight I know
right dude Vegas would go crazy with
this is awesome
he almost yeah so like that's just an
impossibility though because he's like
busy all the time which I kind of knew
because I I wasn't really want to do it
a second time unless it was garyvee um
you just want to take down all the
finance people
just work your way through one by one he
almost got me with Froggy Fresh though
dude uh do you know Froggy Fresh is he's
fighting the second one okay
um against I think Chris Reagan I think
um actually I'm not exactly sure he's
fighting but
um he is like like early internet he had
like some funny videos like on Tosh.O
like yeah he had like some really funny
[__] early on and now he's like
re-emerge to to fight which is like he
looks jacked as [__] too which I'm
excited yeah oh I gotta see what he
looks like dude from before and then now
it's like crazy he had like a [__]
beard now and like a chest tattoo and
he's like Jack yeah I'm glad yeah I'm
glad I didn't fight him so so but you
were on the edge a little bit like maybe
maybe do it yeah yeah but yeah it's like
crazy I already make like not that many
videos so I think that's probably part
of why that video also took so long it's
like dude like so much time like just
boxing training so yeah yeah you know
how it is but what have you got garyvee
would you really oh yeah you would do it
I would do it I would do it with no
training I would do it I would do
anything you really are that confident I
don't care maybe it'd be the [__] out of
me I don't know because it's funny it's
just funny it's funny yeah I think he's
like I think we're the same height I did
not know that I thought I thought
garyvee was like five eight or yeah I
don't care it doesn't matter
I would do it yeah because that's so
funny he's also like 50. so like that
would be a good Advantage trip that
would be the first I know that would be
funny as [__] that might actually be
fair if he's like 50s taller yeah yeah
but you know you're younger yeah more
agile you're not gonna throw your back
out yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought that
would be funny but I'm I was pretty sure
that he couldn't you know did you
present that to Ian as like a serious or
like yeah like when like this like a
sponsor comes to you and you're like I
don't want to do the sponsor give the
and you quote them really high yeah
that's what that was for but what if he
and called your bluff
yeah 100 yeah because that's funny you
were still down fine yeah yeah is this
you officially calling out garyvee dude
I've done it before oh yeah yeah and has
he responded to you or no
you don't think you would if we get him
on the podcast which I think will
eventually happen people will mention it
yeah okay I'm down because for charity
so like you know does it have to be
filmed I don't care
is there anyone else you would fight
though no no I don't think so I think my
fighting career is done really what
about for a rematch just hypothetically
still hypothetically I wouldn't do it
okay but hypothetically if it I would
not do it either all right am I [__]
yeah dude like yeah I get dizzy from
getting hit in the head too much
especially in sparring yep so what was
your sentiment from the beginning from
like once you first heard that you're
gonna fight Graham through the fight and
then after the fight like how do you
feel about it now versus a week after
the fight because we talked to you
building up to the fight but then what
about like I was just extremely happy
for it to be over because it was like I
was so [__] nervous about it me too
um yeah I was just like sitting in the
garage
and like listening to music and staring
at the floor and like I'd like a mirror
in the garage and I would just like
every time I get nervous just like start
Shadow Boxing and like because that's
like I don't know practice for it so
yeah yeah it was it was yeah it was
nerve-wracking so I'm just glad for it
to be over and then after the fight how
do you feel about it now like reflecting
on it so still I still feel that relief
feeling
I forget who he's fighting but like I
want to be like if if I could be like in
his ear be like yo man just don't put
your hands down like you got this
[__] God yes dude hear some songs
dude just be a Hitmonchan you know yeah
you could do that you [__] got it
yeah yeah dude it's [__] so happy
it's over I was just listening to music
[__] trying to not think it was yeah
understood yeah but you've kept up with
your boxing right not really no no no I
I no there was like got big
I was trying to because like my
um my coach from last time is training a
lot of the people in the next one so I'm
a good sparring partner for a lot of
them so I did some sparrings for them
like I sparked toast he he yeah yeah and
that was good
um but then I like took a lot I'm trying
to get back into like just like getting
my cardio and [__] back up to like be a
better sparring partner for them but not
a lot recently yeah and what was the
most nerve-wracking part of it all
because it seems like a pretty like high
anxiety thing was it the fact that it
was in front of a bunch of people or
like a live audience I don't think the
audience was the issue cameras was scary
I mean they're being cameras but I mean
honestly like you know once you were in
the ring it was like it kind of just all
was black for me was the audience though
oh yeah because like sparring it's just
like I just focused on the other person
yeah but I guess with this it's like
there's distractions it's like a
screaming and I'm in my head I'm like
everything I do is being watched
if I do anything wrong then it's like
everyone more like pressure yeah yeah I
don't know just the whole thing also for
um
I also had the added thing like the
video that I was making for it I was
like oh [__] on top of the vid on top of
the fight it's like also the video will
now be heavily impacted by the like
whatever happens like I don't know yeah
my conclusion is like entirely dependent
on on the fight and like if I you know
look like [__] or not so that was that
was scary
um yeah you did great though you had
moves that I didn't even know existed
when you would like go like your back
would just Arch like it was like under
like a scorpion sort of deal my coach is
a crazy [__] yeah he is like such an
excellent he's also like he's like
you know he's like close to like our age
too so he's like yeah yeah it's like I
[__] forget he's got to be like 29 or
something or like 30. really yeah and so
he's like you know he's just like your
boy dude I just assumed he was like a
really like good looking 45 year old
yeah you think you know because he seems
like he has a lot of experience he does
he uh he was a golden gloves for
California so like he won in his
division he did like he went to like
Nationals and [__]
um he's like an extremely like well
accredited boxer and he like really
knows how to fight and teach how to
fight good motivation yeah how do you
have to be training like what was that
about oh well he'd like a dude it was
super lucky um he would like uh thank
God it was all covered by Ian but he'd
like come to my house and we would just
like train near my garage in my garage I
put up like a punching bag and he'd like
bring myths and like have me do [__]
myths and sticks and like run the
ladders and [__] and then after that I'd
like go do cardio at the gym and like
just run on the treadmill for a while I
[__] my legs pretty bad running um
and also knees got really bad my hip
also got pretty bad sorry so I switched
a treadmill and that kind of helped but
oh he'd have us run up Griffith every
like other week which was pretty sweet
he took us on the same route he trained
at the same gym uh Manny Pacquiao
trained at oh wow so he took us on like
the same or like half of the same route
not the whole and so what was the route
though what would you be doing it was
just from like bottom to top you know
you just like jog all the way up
um in the middle is the observatory you
do [__] crunches get our crunches and
push-ups out of the way in the middle
this was not super awesome it's like
every other week sometimes every two
weeks um and then like go all the way to
the top of the mountain after that
um and you look like a huge [__]
doing that at the observatory you look
like just the biggest [__] ever doing
Shadow Boxing
it's embarrassing so embarrassing each
other yeah but dude he's so [__] like
you got it dude you [__] God he'll
like do it with you so it's like less
embarrassing
um yeah because I see guys at the gym
every now and then through the shadow
boxing and it's always the kind of weird
ones that do that yeah
I don't want to be the weirdest they all
look really aggressive oh dude yeah so
I'm like who are you pretending to fight
and I imagine they they imagine they're
like they hitting somebody dude they
definitely have someone in mind a
particular person in mind yeah those
people are weird so that was
embarrassing to do
um
now that you don't have to do the
training uh great I enjoy actually I
still do the training or I do once a
week once a week sometimes every other
week depending on what the schedule is
like yeah it's it's good it's good
afterwards I hate going into it yeah
because I don't feel like it but then
after I finish I'm like I'm glad I went
right it's always a good thing
afterwards yeah yeah
but the training was tough yeah God hey
we don't have to do it anymore I know I
know
oh you know what it was funny I was
talking to Dr Mike about this and he
said that um he recommended a um what
like a sports I forget like not a
therapist but like a psychologist what
was it forget the term for it but
there's like a like a sports like a like
a pep talker oh yeah a hype man yeah but
but there's like a there's a scientific
way about it where they where they
do it in such a way where maybe it's
more I don't know yeah like a sports
psychologist yeah maybe maybe that's
yeah yeah yeah yeah those are real that
like because I was saying like the
biggest fear for me was just like the
fear itself and like getting up in front
of all these people and like yeah he
says oh there's ways that you could
combat that and you should have done
this I was like I didn't even know that
existed right yeah yeah it's like a lot
of [__] yeah so I think he started doing
that
um after a second but I think he wants
to take it more seriously he is right
he's like I'm getting heavy heavy right
that's
exciting and scary and is he fighting a
boxer yeah well he fought like a real
boxer last time and he I think that was
like an MMA right now yes Nick Diaz
he should he did well he didn't win but
he did well I mean it's a really scary
guy yeah yeah that is freaky kind of MMA
animal those guys moved like it's a
doctor it's like I don't know I feel
like his mind is so like you shouldn't
you shouldn't mess with that yeah I did
I don't know how many more punches I can
take I'm probably like lose it
so yeah doing it consistently is crazy
like going to a consistent sparring
you're getting hit consistently yeah CT
yeah you sparred way more than I did I
think I only got like two sessions and
something like that but you were like
yeah my coach was very adamant about
like sparring is necessary and I think
it was good dude yeah dude I was a dude
[__] holding back tears my first
fight or my first sparring yeah I was
like why'd you hit me I mean it's like
who is the who's the first oh it was
like it was like I mean it's all good
but it was like just like a human
reaction of like someone hitting you in
the face it's like weird right yeah and
it's like yeah getting over that hump
was was a good experience yeah yeah it's
interesting when the coaches do that
because they hit you in such a way they
they like do this and you go down like
that and then they get you at the top
yeah you know they know like what you're
gonna do what you're gonna do like it's
like chess it's interesting it really is
yeah like they'll do it they'll do a jab
to the gut and you go oh like that but
then you put this hand down and they go
like that now what if they train you
they're like okay you know you you look
like you're gonna get punched in the gut
you you gotta lean to the side and they
train you that way and then they know if
they go for a gun
ideally you want to do that but then you
but then you could throw like you know
I'm gonna hit hit the head so you have
to put it but I'm just gonna surprise it
yeah I'm just gonna fix it and then you
you do that and then they go down like
your weaknesses and stuff yeah they'll
tell you and then I still [__] do it
you know yeah it's so hard to get rid of
some of those yeah it's incredible like
I think thinking and work that goes into
that I think that's where things went
wrong for you Graham is the the lack of
sparring like a simulated real fight I
feel like especially with such a little
time to practice is the best way to get
decent in uh the amount I hated it I
hate it I hated
like the headgear and everything and
dude I think headgear is only so you
don't get like cuts on your face like
you've I mean it's still like just like
those pain 90 of the impact to sit in
your head yeah and like you can still
get the headaches and stuff like it's
just so your like nose doesn't get yeah
the coach was telling me that
concussions I think are more common with
them yeah
more surface area yeah but yeah I think
it's cuts
um it helps protect your nose a little
bit Yeah but like you could still like
you get punched right in the middle it's
like it doesn't offer that much
protection yeah sparring is intense dude
I spot some sparred some people that
like the the gym that my coach trains
out of now it's called CM Stables
um unless people are
crazy they all like you know like went
easy and like worked with me but it like
still they hit you with like such a hard
[__] this one girl named Norma dude it
was really useful because it was I
actually got a great variety of people
so it's like some people who like were
really defensive and then some people
who were like really agile moved around
a lot
um so it was like good to see the
different styles and like try to adapt
to different [__] she would just like do
this and like cover every Turtle yeah
turtle and then once you got push you
would [__] like just like the
strongest hooks ever that was the
dizziest ever but I think I got a small
concussion from that really yeah it's
about her as part um this kid named
Jaden who is like he he's 14 years old
but he is the best 14 year old in the
country so
because he beat the [__] out of me I
think that's okay because he's the best
no no no no he was like he was like
fighting Aang from Avatar The Last
Airbender he was like he would just like
jab use three times and then like
and then like and he would he was like
like I was in the center and he was just
like like [__] Hubble Space Telescope
orbiting the [__] out of me he was like
always moving were you bigger than him
yeah well yeah yeah I'm like I mean you
know I'm an adult and he's 14 years old
he could definitely beat the [__] out of
me
there's a big difference yeah there are
yeah like we could be some they're six
foot tall I think we're about the same
beard you know yeah but he was just like
incredibly fast and like just a
disgusting amount of stuff like he is
the best 14 year old boxer in the entire
United States were you scared before you
fought him uh a little bit I mean like
he I think he was also going easy and
not hitting me super hard which was nice
um was part of you like yeah he's fine
no at no point they look so scary dude
they all look like cuts on their eyes
everyone in boxes though was like they
got mustard
yeah they all chiseled at no point was I
like yeah [__] it's it's a kid no no
it's like yeah no okay no yeah do you
talk to him beforehand yeah yeah
actually I think that's that's that was
part of my strategy yeah was to
establish a relationship so they'd go
easier on me yeah I would like talk
during the sparring and be like oh good
one oh I did the same thing yeah I did
the same thing
yeah humanize yourself yeah yeah make
yourself a more vulnerable
you know that one kind of hurt
same thing yeah
it's a defensive
yeah yeah that's funny
yeah
do anyone like do any of them watch your
Channel or do they know who you are yeah
okay which is good yeah that should be
nice but did they know you from like
YouTube at all or like from twitch no
nothing I don't know our coaches like
always like talking about like the
YouTube stuff now and
he's always like doing [__] about it
yeah so they they know now cool yeah I
think they still think it's maybe like a
little stupid but they're all extremely
nice yeah yeah so what do you think
about Ian fighting uh Alex Wasabi right
now oh dude that's gonna be crazy who do
you think I think I think my money's on
Ian because she's got that experience
right now he's been fighting for like
years
oh really you know Alex was he has a
[__] boxing ring in his backyard for
how long I thought this was like a
recent thing no no no he's been doing
this they both they both got a lot of
experience
um still I wanted to say Ian because I
just want to see that happen yeah yeah
yeah in one in my heart also for the for
the last Creator Clash that was awesome
yeah just seeing him go through it yeah
it was in you know oh gosh yes good
fight yeah I felt bad on stage I just
wanted I wanted to call it guys all
right if we did enough good show we got
a show though he like really showed the
like his endurance but like seeing him
right after with the black eye and like
the puffy face yeah yeah bad yeah I
would also feel bad for him though if
you called it early and like he because
he's still obviously had [__] yeah you
know right and it's like you don't want
to call it while he's like still able to
fight
I would have stopped earlier but
give them both if you know just to say
you both won
as long as you do that would be
hilarious just everyone wins as long as
you get up there you you want something
dude
dude holy [__] it's gonna be sweet I'm
excited for um do you know who's uh
Sabrina is
um she's like
um I think she's in like the really
lightweight um female fighting uh
section of the fight so and she's like I
I don't actually know she's fighting but
she was at the same gym that I was at
like my coach trains out of sometimes
she just comes for fun
um and like she just punches so [__]
much she's like a volume puncher and so
that's gonna be awesome to see that's
like super overwhelming for most people
me included like whenever like someone's
just throwing combos it's like I just
shut my brain off yeah
um yeah so I'm excited for that one I'm
just excited to go I think I think it's
all leveling up now because everyone saw
the first one
for real yeah yeah like the bar is now
set at that level and you have to
surpass that by like probably two-fold
yeah yeah thank God we did the first one
and not the second one's like two times
as big for the crowd yeah you see that I
don't think I do this is it a different
Stadium like a bigger Arena it's like a
2X Stadium oh 2x on what we were at I
think it went from 10 000 to 20 000.
whatever
yeah yeah
it'll be high it'll be sick cheers
does Lily not want to fight
no I don't think she wants to get hit in
the head no yeah no she doesn't she
likes learning like little boxing stuff
um like punching and stuff yeah she's
pretty good at driving I think it's
interesting that Dad is gonna fight
again
that's excellent for that me too yeah
isn't he fighting someone that's like
kind of like signing a b yeah yeah he's
kind of big right it was big and pretty
good yeah but dad is crazy yeah if I
were a B I would be I would be so sorry
I would be terrified yeah I think he
could like probably snake that a couple
you know because Dad was like putting
his hands I mean like I'm loaded yeah
yeah like his hands are like down like
maybe ABIA is like seeing it and being
like I could yeah but so is that Dad
dad's saying that too and like you know
don't be so scared I'm not gonna do that
my favorite though is The Joe Rogan clip
it's like the father's literally beating
the [__] out of the Sun the best place
and he's enjoying it yeah the sun gets
you know knocked out and the dad's just
like she's cheering too
so funny that was an incredible clip
what do you guys think do you think he's
gonna go out like the same that he did
the first creative class just run out or
something punching and hopefully I don't
know I feel like preparing for that I
feel like everyone's expecting that so
he'd be smart to like do something a
little different think about like go
slow and then Sprint up you know like I
guess I'll see that's why I'm excited to
go I can't [__] wait what did you
think of when you were in the [__]
back room and you saw the [__] did
you have a TV you had a TV we had the TV
dude it was a tiny little thing too oh
really yeah and you saw the Matt Watson
fight what did you like what was going
through your head I was terrified dude
that was the moment where I was like I
was kind of hoping people were taking it
easy like you know like you know the
sparring were like good hit like that's
what I thought it was going to be like
yeah just gentle dude just gentle like
little Jabs here and there nothing
nothing crazy
I thought how mismatched is it like if
if this was the first one that's exactly
what I thought I was like is everything
gonna be like yeah
but then he kept getting hit my my
biggest thing was just watching people
like go up there and then come back and
you see the before and afters of people
like they're going up they're scared and
they're terrified and they come back and
they're just like limping in and they
got like back on the side of their face
they're like you gotta go to the
hospital yeah but everyone is doing that
and then I'm thinking like I can't
escape that like there's no way that
like I'm gonna be the exception of just
like not being hurt at all that buildup
was [__] to be like later on in the
fights dude seeing the Ryan McGee Alex
crazy yeah yeah they came back and they
were like holy yeah I think he went to
the hospital right yeah yeah he did he I
think he broke his nose yeah concussion
concussion yeah I remember seeing his
nose and it was like huge yeah it's
absolutely massive and they had the the
stuff they stuffed his nose in the
middle and um and his eye was like just
completely red like there's no white and
yeah it was red that was an awesome
fight it was a crazy fight but I would
would have loved to have gone first
yeah I think so too yeah and plus like
people were still kind of like filling
in the the seats yeah yeah first get it
out of the way you know not everyone
gets to see it that really set the stage
in that site yeah right and Jack and I
were gonna do the uh what is it the
liver King thing
oh the Barbarian the Barb yeah he
invited us to do a barbarian and it
involves holding what is it 80 pounds
it's like it's 80 pounds is it 80. yeah
I think it was 80 pounds okay 80 pound
kettlebell kettlebells in each other
hand with 100 pounds in the back a
backpack plus ankle weights and you're
like dragging dragging like a 200 pound
sled you gotta walk a mile you'll walk a
mile through that yeah it's crazy so I
was thinking Well Jack there's no way
Jack and I should have the same weights
right if someone if someone's like six
foot tall six foot five let's just say
they weigh 250 pounds I shouldn't carry
the same weight as that person it
doesn't make sense definitely not it
should be it should be to body weight
yeah yeah to be a proportion of body
weight that's the only way to keep it
you know keep it fair because otherwise
I'm doing the work of two yeah I don't
know Grant because you've also been
working out for what 10 years now yeah
but like it was not like a thorough
workout I'm talking it's just like a
superficial now people say you have
they're not they're not functional
though they're all they're purely
aesthetic right okay ask me to think of
anything I can't do it
Macy was trying to get me to open a jar
the other day
no it was just on there it took me like
five minutes what did you think man she
like called for you to help you first of
all she couldn't do it okay and then she
goes to me I couldn't do it so I run it
under water for a little bit it was like
a pasta sauce jaw jar and it just was
just stuck [__] on there yeah yeah
I'd blow torched that yeah yeah you
gotta do something I got it off though
but yeah they feel good it did but it's
also the um like if it's a if it's a
wide jar it's hard for me to like get a
good grasp on it right even if it's a
smaller jar yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll do
it yeah yeah it's hard to find a thing
that's your size yeah
too tough five foot three life it's
[__] sweet dude it's actually so hard
to find a motorcycle that I could fit on
properly 100 Ruckus uh yeah see that's
what I'm saying yeah yeah
no I just did the one foot thing
right yeah I would think the same thing
with motorcycles like just being able to
put your foot down and you're at a red
light without the whole thing toppling
over yeah you got to do like a
like the the one footer instead of like
normally like a lot of people just do
the two Footers yeah you just like you
just must gain the skill that much 250s
are pretty big yeah yeah
like a 689 and that that one is much
larger so what are your plans for the
future how do you envision the perfect
Michael leaves Reeves like a leaves
Michael leaves life in five years
um maybe I'll be in Japan for a year
that'll be fun yeah maybe hopefully
sooner yeah I want to
um
a thing about going like on more road
trips would be fun up the west coast of
the PCH would be super fun that is cool
be super sweet I'd love to see vlogs if
you just did a vlog I'm on yeah
once a week I'm doing yeah doing one a a
cool thing happened I wasn't gonna I was
just gonna get the footage and like
listen on patreon but a cool thing did
happen in this Vlog where I was like
okay I could maybe put this on YouTube
can we get a little bit of a I need to
after okay yeah yeah
it happens like right in the middle and
it's like don't talk about it it was fun
it was like um a couple times like the
car the truck broke down and I had to
fix it on like the side of their own
that's like fun trials and tribulations
okay yeah radiator blue and I had to
like do some hose [__] was this the
uh the city car this is the city
000 miles I feel like it could probably
go pretty fast right I mean it I don't
know whoever owned it before did not
treat it well so like on the highway for
a consistent amount of time it heats up
so [__] fast okay yeah the radiator's
absolutely [__] up so how many
vehicles you have now you still have the
Tesla
I think so yeah oh yeah yeah we have a
very we have a large parking lot in the
backyard yeah oh nice yeah I mean the
truck is like like a work truck you know
I don't drive it anywhere yeah right
yeah and I don't really drive my car
anymore it's just the motorcycles I just
do the bikes around town yeah yeah it's
much nicer around La that's what Ludwig
does I mean he rides yeah motorcycle
license you did yeah you got it you took
the test on my bike wow no wait wait I
didn't know you you got the Vespa
recently
um oh no I think his vespa's legal to
ride without it or he was oh it could be
less than 50cc yeah maybe yeah yeah yeah
when I saw that I was so jealous man was
so fun yeah I told you Grandma I was
like dude he looks so cool on that vesma
that looks like it's so fun Investments
are sweet yeah like a scooter scooting
around yeah yeah not in city traffic but
like going up like the like a road to
like Griffith is quite nice at like the
sun sunset they sell 49cc Vespas like
they purposely make a model that's 49cc
to bypass the California
around yeah I think you just need a
driver's license yeah all you need is a
driver's license yeah so you get you
just do it like tomorrow I mean
technically you can buy any motorcycle
without a driver's license they just
sell it to you and they're like let's
drive it on the road yeah
there you go
I don't know how you're getting it home
yeah
I'm gonna go this way now and I'll see
you later yeah yeah but yeah you can do
it and it's fun on like a like a back
road or like Sunset is super nice dude
the line to get to Griffith is like so
long that you just like drive past all
of them because you're just like I'm
really I feel like one car is gonna go
like the other way would you hop on a a
motorcycle on a scooter on a Vespa or
something like that that's what it
depends where I would I would but it's
not now dirt road wouldn't do it yeah oh
yeah that's easy yeah yeah you could I
feel like you do in your neighborhood in
Vegas maybe yeah yeah it's fine yeah
that'd be fun you get 100 Ruckus yeah
those can go under a little bit too
those are fun yeah scooters you don't
have to like work a clutch or anything
till you just [__] hop on and I could
do that twist the thing yeah it looks
sweet my neighbors in L.A we I don't
know if you remember this there's a
whole bunch of kids who lived across the
street and they got one of those little
tiny motorcycles like they're really
tiny ones yeah their legs would be like
up in the air would be like a pocket
rocket yeah dude it would ride that
thing up and down the street but it was
so loud and they would go late at night
and so sometimes I'm filming like I'm
talking 10 p.m at night
just like just up and down for hours
and the thing is they must have been
like 12 or 13. I don't think their
parents really like yeah I had any
involvement in them but they were just
like just up and down the street it was
fun dude yeah that's [__] yeah dude I
was so jealous of kids in my
neighborhood who had like little pocket
rockets just like flying around yeah
it's like 25 cc yep it's like barely a
[__] lawnmower
it sounds like a lawnmower though yeah
yeah yeah it probably is like the same
engine I think so some weed whackers
yeah like a two-stroke [__] thing
gosh yeah yeah so I want to do more of
that like just like I get that do some
like long road trip traveling is fun I
really liked my um road trip to Boston
when I did like the dog piss video I
liked that that was yeah shoot that was
super nice because like like a lot of
the time I'm like damn I should be
working or doing something but it's like
I literally could not be because I'm
like my only mission is to just drive to
a place like I couldn't work if I wanted
to yeah you know so did you take your
time on the trip or was it like I took
some time yeah okay um I like stopped in
like a couple spots Utah was like super
beautiful I think we talked about that a
little last time actually
um yeah so something like that again
yeah like really nice yeah your
dedication to the video is mind-blowing
to me like going to Vegas for just that
one like we're talking like 10 seconds
20 seconds of a clip but it's like a
whole day trip for 10 seconds yeah it
makes sense though that one yeah that
was fun that was good did the Boston
trip was sweet I think I kind of wanted
to do the road trip anyway and I was
like you get a video yeah sure yeah yeah
so that was that was excellent yeah it'd
be fun if you did something with AI like
just Incorporated like a chat GPT of
some sort of like a you know yeah I'll
do something like that
shit's going crazy have you seen those
um
uh AI generated
um president playing like fortnite
voices yes dude is it the funniest
videos the greatest memes I've seen in
recent history I haven't seen them
they're so it'll be like [__] Obama
you need to hop on Roblox right now
and like dude [__] like Joe Biden
Trump [__] Obama Hillary Clinton and
like a Minecraft server like and the
voices sound like they sound real yeah
I heard a Joe Biden one yeah it sounds
pretty good yeah there's like one [__] I
saw this video of like a dude showing
one to his his mom and it's like Joe
Biden talking about like the stickiest
ickiest Wheaties ever smoked he's like
this [__] this [__] will stop your
pacemaker this has been watered with the
blood of 36 dragons
and his mom is like
well you know what people are going to
believe in it that's that's the thing
you know some people use for memes and
it's so good you might say that Joe
Rogan thing it's funny I think I sent
you this Jack that's like as soon as it
came up The Joe Rogan thing where he's
selling testosterone pills yeah uh I was
scrolling Tick Tock and all of a sudden
there was this guy I was talking about
like these testosterone pills and Joe
Rogan you see him yeah these pills are
the best I go for like Alpha you know
whatever it is and I'm looking because
it seems a little off yeah I realized
it's AI it's not even Joe Rogan it's Ai
and like you see his mouth moving but
it's not perfect yeah and it seems a
little off but like it it's it looks so
legit it's like Alpha grind or something
like that and I sent it to you like as
soon as it came out is it a fake ad yes
yeah they like totally faked this guy so
yeah so what they did they went on The
Joe Rogan show and there was another guy
the other guy was legitimately talking
about the benefits of testosterone yeah
then they come back to to Joe and Joe's
AI now yeah so you know I totally agree
with that point that's why I do that
yeah yeah particle yeah yeah that's why
I use Alpha grind they're number one on
the Amazon store I'm like it's it's you
know what actually I didn't catch it at
first but Amazon story but it sounded
too much like an ad wait a second This
sounds too salesy like he wouldn't say
this yeah and then I looked into it it's
like that's a real thing dude that's
correct the future's gonna be awesome
yeah she's gonna be sweet I hope I die
by the time but I but you know what but
like I will at some point there's gotta
be like a verification tag like if if a
computer is able to see that you're
online
like there's some sort of blue check
mark or something that you've approved
that or that that's actually you yeah or
just that it's not like a deep fake
video I think I'm working on stuff where
it's like you can tell if it's like a
deep fake thing how would they be able
to tell I don't even [__] know I
don't know I'm really bad at AI stuff
yeah I'm not sure all I know is I love
the memes Joe Rogan talking to Jordan
Peterson about his Minecraft build yeah
so too much God I saw that exact same
thing yeah those are they're incredible
right over here oh my gosh I would love
that I've been just like 20 of them it
was literally they're so like low effort
to make usually too that there's just
like they're in a lot of them now and
they're so funny they're just so [__]
[__] means yeah we could have an
intro like that for the iced coffee hour
that would be interesting and then we
say oh this intro was just all AI that
would be cool no or say that we paid for
it on cameo
that would be cool too yeah that'd be
sweet it just just play it off as like
hey this is real yeah you own the
Michael Reed 2 channel right is that you
or is that no that's something no I
don't that is just something right oh I
did
oh it was you were telling me on the
other podcast oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
what podcast the OTV one oh you don't
own Michael Reed too no that's just a
random person no I talked to him now and
again and I'm like
no it's not not me
um yeah yeah kind of how is that channel
doing I feel like it's good I'm trying
to get him to pay me he's probably
making more money than mine here's
something you could come up with some
sort of like contract be like yo I'll
take 50 of Michael retoo and I'll send
you on random occasion little tidbits of
like yeah I've talked to him before
original footage I just would rather
have it not have him but it's always
going to happen like a second really
someone clipping you don't think that's
you would rather not not happen I would
rather a second channel that is like
pretending to be me did not exist but
I'm I feel like it will probably always
happen I think it's good for you because
you're posting so infrequently that
these these Random clips that like pop
off on YouTube and stuff like that yeah
that keep you random though on top
though between each post yeah it's
pretty random though it's fun it's fun
to get them on the starvation diet
though
they're like do they have to go back
like three years
so it's the reason you're not posting
because of the second chance
I talked to him on Discord sometimes I'm
trying to work something out with him
yeah you still haven't worked something
out with him I'm a lazy person I thought
Rita was here I know it's funny because
it looks a lot like it's so well done
too like the videos are well yeah
they're good titles good thumbnails it
was funny I thought for the longest time
you had a second Channel yeah and
there's something on Creator Clash I
commented as though as though it were
you yeah and then I think they pinned
the comment to the top responded back
like thank you so much and I was like
that's cool Michael responded he's on
YouTube right now that's kind of neat
and I thought like okay it makes sense
that you're not posting as much on your
your main Channel because you got this
thing yeah
no definitely not I wonder this sort of
like deals she's getting because like a
magic you'd be getting sponsors no no
but I'm just saying it's guaranteed
there are companies reaching out as much
it's probably getting offered yeah
guaranteed probably yeah then he'll
start using like AI to start guys
this is how I won the boxing match
I only ate Alpha
woke up Alpha grind went to bed Alpha
grind it's number one on the Amazon
store
and you can order now before they run
out unreal
tea they could they could be taking
crazy sponsorship deals yeah yeah
I would just I would hire the guy
honestly you honestly could I would I
would hire that person he's already
doing all the work you know yeah yeah
how many subscribers does he have a few
hundred thousand I thought more the
videos pop off yeah no I thought it was
like a million subscribers probably
I want to say like 400
0 513
000 subscribers that's about right bro
but dude the views he's pulling I can't
look at it it doesn't make you sick but
they're all they're all over eight
minutes he purposely makes eight minutes
and three seconds before him
every video is just barely overrated how
much they're making in ad Revenue yes
what is it I can't you can't say I can't
think of anything about it Michael can
you not just like reach out I did I did
I know but just like work something out
or he gives a chance I think he said
that it's been getting demonetized like
intensely recently which is why that's
what he wants yeah I know right yeah but
like oh yeah it's not that good though
yeah you don't want us to it yeah
that is absurd so that channel
sorry man 118 million views
that's crazy there's one month he had uh
8.3 million views in a month
wow
this is doing fantastic an average of 75
000 views a day you're doing great Mike
yeah you don't got to worry about it man
don't feel this pressure that you need
to be posting all the time because he's
doing it but you do you man he's doing
it I air this was actually a great video
I actually I watched this one Michael
Reeves being a comedy genius for 18
minutes I'm like it's a fantastic video
though it's like really well like the
amount of research and time to make life
and all together
like that's probably like a few days
worth of work if someone were to go
through all of your videos and like you
know organize them yeah dude I wonder
how many times he's combed through the
library
so it's like it's not that hard
it knows every video word for word he
just smells it as he's a bad clip he's
like okay I gotta use this yeah
it's getting time off blood again and
what about getting someone else just
like you know you give someone else
power of attorney they they do all the
work on your behalf to like just get in
contact like work with the guy yeah
maybe like you don't want to shut him
down but like work with him he's
obviously talented at what he's doing or
hire him jack for like for Clips we
could use him for like our Clips Channel
and stuff like that you know dude yeah
well you'll know to reach out when you
get sponsored by Alpha grind
he's gonna contact me and be like can
you do that right now yes yes
my AI is no longer working I just did
yeah I just need to see these
these dude wait we can do that if he
reached out and was like yo I found a
sponsored I'll give you 50 of the
revenue would you do it only if it was
like something super funny like no like
Adam and Eve or something oh yeah like
flashlight
dude
yeah it's a company I wanted to do a
video with them where they were like
offering sponsorships but they never
contacted me I said I needed like 300
flashlights for a video and they didn't
ever contact me again what what was the
video I think I was gonna make like a
raft out of flashlights or something
like a boat
just I think the it wasn't like like the
thing it was more interesting to see how
many flashlights I could get from the
flashlights and just like the dumbest
[__] thing ever with it
I just like do they float yeah yeah does
it freeze yeah it's like do random stuff
I really wanted 300 because that's the
only way it's like funny huh 300 yeah
like 300 flashlights I think 100
flashlights no dude
some I don't know I don't know how much
would we needed to make a raft be funny
to go to Marina del Rey and like make a
legit like wrap see if you get it from
the beginning of the harbor to the end
what if they just don't float from the
start I bet I bet you could take it out
of the plastic and like blow it with
compressed air to make a balloon Okay
and like yeah like pontoons like a
hovercraft around my boat and the main
structure is like why did you get up on
that man 300 flashlights I I was ready I
had the vision I was so ready to make
this [__] that's a good game for it
how much would that cost 300 flashlights
yeah I don't know I've never bought a
flashlight but how much would that cost
I mean like would cost them what about
17.99 her flashlight
yeah
use my referral link oh gosh this is now
now it's in my search and now I'm gonna
get ads for this where can I buy 300
flashlights uh oh wow okay so the really
cheap ones are
19.95 1766 like right yeah that's funny
that's the Mia Khalifa one damn that's
why it's not about you even the names of
these two oh yeah they name them Mia
class we got stroker [__] Jack Strokers
it's called dude
Mia Khalifa stroker see Stroker
hahaha
[Music]
Joker stroker this is the boss level for
eighty dollars boss level dude what do
you what is that the boss level you know
you have to explain this you have to
clean those yourself oh man dishwasher
safe then we got mistress Mercedes Vibe
mouth stroker Cho damn I don't like I
don't want that it only has one stroker
in the name
uh some of them are real molds of real
people Series yeah I can't look at that
anymore what okay so anyway the answer
is twenty dollars that's the answer yeah
like twenty six thousand dollars
probably at cost too for them is like
you know because they're amazing it's
like I bet it's like five bucks or
something it's got it yeah yeah this is
like five times like 300 they're they're
under like two grand for that investment
I just want 300 flashlights at cost
so it doesn't matter like if I were to
buy you 300 flashlights you wouldn't I
think it's funny if it's from them you
know because like it's obviously not
about what I make with it's like I just
want to see how many I could like
squeeze out of them like how many little
centers
dude I want to get like a palette of
flashlights arriving to my door like my
forklifts would be so awesome yeah they
just never messaged me again which is
sad that would be great but did you get
in contact with them I did originally I
was on LinkedIn huh that sounds like the
best way to get into contact with it
dude YouTube DM or sorry Twitter DM and
yeah okay 300 degrees for this and I
think they just never talked again about
it yeah why wouldn't you have Michael
Reeves to reach out for you oh yeah yeah
he could be doing everything for you man
I [__] [__] I'm just a puppet
actually
yeah
this is heart and soul behind this whole
operation he tells me what to say
I would honestly I'd hire him yeah no I
would hire him I don't think he lives in
the United States too
dude he's Megan and Kellen I know hire
him hire him to do this
what other ideas like this have you just
like scrapped because the company yeah I
don't know I can't think of him off the
top of the head there's a I think
there's probably a couple but I don't
really remember well I just asked for
something outrageous like maybe they'll
give it to me that's funny I know right
dude
300 especially if you're ballooning them
I mean no it's like I would imagine it's
a science it's 300 300 water bottles I
can't imagine it being like that much
like a case of 24 is like but you're
ballooning them the thing is he's
blowing them up no but I'm singing like
yeah
my guess the palette would be like about
the size of this and probably like that
so it's like this is for 24. this is
like a water bottle yeah it's like 24.
it's not too bad it's like 24 times like
a foot and a half by a foot
out of the blown up ones that would be
so sick
God damn dude you can make like a
[__] water balloon with the [__]
airbag out of them yeah they're gonna
shoot that down so fast
flashlight
[__] yeah so what does a video need to
pass like what what is the litmus test
you push push video ideas through in
order to say okay this is good enough to
make a video I don't even know I if I
like just [__] around with it and it
gets out of hand it's probably gonna
become if you like because I'm sure
since there's such a large period of
time between each video I'm sure you
come up with plenty of ideas through
that time but what is it that you just
don't know like how do you know that
it's a actual main Channel video idea I
don't know usually I'll just [__] get
too far on it [__] around with it and
it has to become a video now and then or
like if I don't get super far it's
because I've like already shot it down
um I think I'm I'm gonna start I've
already started working on like the next
one which is like
not the greatest idea but I've already
already gotten pretty far and I could
make it pretty quick I think
um it's not the Vlog thing it's like
tease it no we got to get a hint there's
like nothing or like it's about videos
it's a video about videos okay yeah deal
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um which isn't a super good idea but I
think it'd just be fun to make how'd you
get the idea
[__] I don't remember maybe something
yeah and I don't really remember all
right I just thought it would be fun as
well as working on like the last one I
feel like this would be interesting and
what's your timeline to have that posted
by I don't know Michael Reeves two needs
to know he's got Maps
he has mouths to feed he's a family man
just think of it
no dude no I have no idea I'm gonna do
the Vlog first and then
maybe go on a road trip and then make
the other video Yeah PCH baby that
sounds fun yeah yeah I think so I
actually recently just took a road trip
up to Oregon and but it was on like the
five where'd you go in Oregon uh we went
to Ashland but we were there for like a
20 minutes we're helping my friend move
so we're getting this stuff bring it
back
um it's a really fun road trip though
and I think it would be even better
looking on the PCH it'd be slower but
the five is just like really starts
really beautiful and like
and then it's just like dog [__] yeah
cornfields for like 300 miles yeah oh I
got something interesting to tell you
yeah I uh posted a clip on my channel it
was the uh scarra's credit score
remember he said that someone stole his
credit yeah card or his credit score and
there's like a trade line and someone
was like paying it off yeah I didn't
realize that that's very common uh with
some people who
um pay for a social security number they
apply for a credit card but they don't
want to screw anybody over so they'll
open up a card or take out a loan but
pay it off oh and so they said most
likely his credit card information or
not his credit card his his identity had
been leaked somebody purchased it but
without like malicious intent he's got
like a benevolent credit card identity I
don't know if that's what benevolent
means I think it's close enough yeah
yeah he's got like a like a guardian
angel yeah social security number but
like I got multiple comments be like
yeah it's not that uncommon you don't
want to be like a huge [__] right
yeah and like if you just don't want to
you can't or like you can't go through
the process of getting a social right
exactly so it's like you do that but you
don't want to like screw someone else
yeah yeah and you want like more credit
from that so it's like you're not gonna
like you know bite the hand that feeds
so like you're gonna pay it off indeed
that's crazy someone has to like go to
that extent to to get that to get like a
social security
to be a great citizen yeah
financially literate yeah understanding
the due dates not caring interest no
balances on that card growing someone
else's credit yeah they're kind of doing
a service yeah in a way they are yeah I
mean it could it could have gone really
bad yeah but it went well yeah so
it's just a fun resolution there I
didn't think of that yeah
cool cool I think was there anything
else you want to mention
I think so no no what are you up to
tonight I'm gonna work out my video
actually okay I'm liking it good pretty
fun part to edit right now of the Vlog
really yeah nothing else it's fun yeah
it's like
kind of wild event happened to me are
you gonna post it before Creator Clash
or after before for sure cool I think
I'm trying to get it out by like
I don't know middle of next month really
at least those poor starving patreon
okay
I really hope you posted on the main
Channel if not then it's a then it's a
good answer too
I'll give it to Michael Reed too and he
can post it oh yeah yeah yeah
all right man well thank you so much I
really appreciate this anytime you get
your free stock Down Below in the
description
a lot of people think he died yeah look
at that a lot of people think he died I
don't know what's with that everyone has
this just happened terrible they're like
oh wow oh yeah yeah really I keep him
alive yeah you like him I love you you
got a good tank for him you got good
filtration yeah dude my my um uh my
water source is just really good I have
like the full RO system underneath yeah
dude if my landlord looks under my sink
he's gonna think I'm cooking meth under
that thing dude it looks it's like it
was like a three-stage filter four stage
four with a demoniator are you serious
dude I wanted that fish to live I mean I
still want the fish obviously it's still
alive yeah yeah get scallops or
something like that yeah maybe yeah I'm
afraid what is a scallop is that a
clance
male clam it's a mollusk Jack why does
it look like a meatball then when it
that's on the inside eat it but how is
that how is there that much meat inside
of a clam because that's what they
filter feed with yeah you have the two
shells and you pull open the shell and
that's the meat on the inside like
you've seen my the clam that's what it
is yes no there was a lot of meat in
that clam yeah well that's that's a
different type of clam okay yeah
I guess I'm just picturing the mall is
in the ocean they just have two shells
and then they slightly open up and they
have little tentacles that are on the
outside
yeah
and they'll just filter feed thanks for
explaining that yeah yeah so
cool cool there you go yeah thank you
thank you I think now we covered
everything yeah we did it every time
thank you man appreciate it yeah oh yeah
let me just take a picture